pendant que les Français sont en
vacances le pays ne s'arrête pas de
tourner pour autant et ainsi selon la
tradition on fait en ce moment un
certain nombre de comptes celui des
prestations familiales n'est pas le
moins important et au 1er août des
augmentations vont donc intervenir il
s'agit de combler le décalage créé par
la hausse des prix en France demain le
conseil d'administration de la Caisse
nationale d'allocation familiale doit se
prononcer sur un train de mesur de
revalorisation intéressant les
familles c'est mesure quelles sont-elles
en premier lieu la revalorisation de 9,9
% des allocations familiales au 1emè
aoutt d'autres majorations sont
également prévues celle de l'allocation
de salaire unique et de la mer au foyer
qui passerait de 170 francs 80 à 194
francs 10 par mois pour cette dernière
un effet rétroactif est prévu au 1er
juillet soit une revalorisation de 13,64
%. une autre majoration celle du montant
maximum de l'allocation pour frais de
garde qui mensuellement passerait de 268
francs 05 à 291 francs
35 enfin laallocation de rentrée
scolaire à partir du 1er septembre
serait relevée de 9,9 % ce train de
mesure conviendra-t-il aux intéressés
c'est déjà en tout cas nettement moins
que ce que l'Union nationale des
associations familiales estime
nécessaire aux prestations pour suivre
l'évolution des salaires c'est-à-dire
16,5 %. l'UNAF s'appuie sur un argument
de poids les rentes de vieillesse les
rentes d'invalidité évoluent déjà comme
les salaires pour l'UNAF les familles
devrait bénéficier du même
avantage